billy eilish and actor matthew tyler
vorse were just spotted out together
and now fans are speculating that sparks
are flying
dude here's the thing bro the two were
photographed grabbing coffee while out
and about in santa barbara california
this week
that's the grammy winner casually
dressed in black biker shorts and a
snoop dogg hoodie
coffee in hand meanwhile the actor
rocked a teal crew neck
jeans a baseball cap and a face mask
also hanging out with billy and matthew
her pitbull
shark i'm like through the roof bro i'm
just happy about it
of course e.t has reached out to billy's
rap for comment
but i bet you want more intel on michael
yeah
i mean naturally here's what we know the
29 year old describes himself as an
la-based quote actor writer degenerate
per his private instagram bio the actor
is known for roles in mother may i sleep
with danger
little monsters and dark hours typey
really really cool and while the two
have yet to address their relationship
status
billy is famously private about her love
life
so much so that she had an entire
relationship people knew nothing about
until billy's apple tv plus documentary
billy eilish the world's a little blurry
came out
which is so incredible and it was so
amazing i cried
parts of the doc showcased her
relationship with now ex-boyfriend q
aka brandon adams but throughout billy's
whirlwind year they
eventually grew apart and split up let
him breathe you know what i'm saying
let him breathe as for billy she's had a
pretty epic year so far
in march she snacked grammys for record
of the year and
best song written for visual media
[Music]
and her brother producing partner
phineas
told et they were running out of room
for all their awards
where do you keep your grammys i keep
them on this shelf
in my living room that's too high for my
dog to knock them over um
but i don't i just we just won this
other one i
i was like i don't know where to put
that one because that shelf is
maxed out so i don't know where to put
it so it's an
embarrassing amount but it's an honor oh
and she also ditched her signature green
and black locks for a platinum blonde do
of course billy is all about evolving
her look
i like to be judged so i wanna i wanna
see heads look up
when e.t chatted with her in 2019 she
said she likes to get people talking
it's really sick it's kind of exactly
what i'd want people to care about you
know
yeah like i don't know the things that
the people sort of know me for are all
the things i want to be known for if
that makes sense because style has
always been something i care about